julio navarro su nombre ha aparecido en
los últimos días citados más de una
ocasión como uno de los expertos en
física que más posibilidades tienen de
obtener el premio nobel indicado a esa
especialidad cómo se llega a esto
así sea es toda profesión a la carrera
de largo de muchos años de contribuir
sobre todo un tema en particular y de
ser reconocido por nuestros padres
nuestros colegas con citaciones con
citas a nuestros trabajos
la empresa que ha hecho este pronóstico
y aparece mi nombre en particular este
año es una empresa que se dedica a esto
a recopilar datos científicos y analizar
y diseñar métricas de que miden el
impacto de estos trabajos en el campo
científico en general
a través de su métrica es tan decidido
que nuestros trabajos
yo estoy galardonado con otras dos
personas son mexicanos que trabajan en
inglaterra hace muchos años y un inglés
que trabaja en alemania hemos sido
citados como de un impacto semejante al
de otros nobel que han a otras personas
que recibe el nobel en años anteriores
vale decir no estamos hablando de una
postulación propiamente dicha de hecho
no hay postulaciones que hagan los
candidatos en sí mismos para un premio
nobel sino de un conjunto de indicios
que podrían llegar a decir que ustedes
cuentan con buenas posibilidades de
ganar ese premio
claro una buena un buen resumen no hay
postulaciones ni nominaciones pero el
nobel no se aceptan se decide por un
comité bien selectivo es muy secreto de
personas que asesoran a la academia
sueca que es la que en general al final
es la que otorga los premios nadie sabe
las deliberaciones son secretas y no se
dan a conocer ni antes ni después más a
una membresía de éstas de estos comités
también es secreta por supuesto que uno
puede intuir quién está aquí no están
pero no hay una lista oficial de esta
gente ahora usted se ha especializado si
podemos decirlo de esa manera en el
estudio de la formación de las galaxias
y el cosmos y la materia oscura
conocido su aporte en ese campo para ser
nombrado como un candidato al nobel
creo que nuestro trabajo es sobre todo
bueno que trata con todos esos temas en
muchos muchos trabajos científicos
yo he publicado más de 200 artículos en
revistas especializadas que han sido
citados 150 mil veces un poco más así
que mi trabajo durante toda mi carrera
ha tenido bastante bastante impacto
dentro de esto el campo le quiso trabajo
y supongo que el trabajo por el cual más
se nos se nos cita o se nos conoce ese
trabajo es el trabajo que hice con estos
dos colegas que le contaba que cuando yo
estaba todavía en inglaterra haciendo un
doctorado y también en arizona haciendo
otro post doctorado en esos años que
fueron al final de los años 90 es cuando
escribimos una serie de artículos
científicos que describen cómo se agrupa
la materia oscura en en pequeños
sistemas individuales esto le llamamos a
los de materia oscura y son básicamente
el nido donde viven las galaxias que
regala que nueve de esas fotos no
hermosas del telescopio hubble por
ejemplo de galaxias y cada mensaje a la
xxxix está rodeada de un halo de materia
oscura
debería estar llamada materia invisible
porque como no interacciona con la luz
uno sabe que está allí por el efecto
gravitatorio que tiene sobre las
estrellas y sobre otras galaxias pero no
se puede ver la luz la atraviesa sin
ningún sin ningún problema no se refleja
no se refracta entonces
inferimos su presencia a través de sus
efectos gravitacionales pero no lo
podemos ver directamente
la explicación que usted da es bastante
clara pero voy a exigirlo un poco más si
me lo permite y entonces le voy a pedir
que le imaginé cómo le explicaría a un
niño que es la materia oscura
y le diría que hay dos tipos de materia
que sabemos en el universo puede ver más
pero al menos hay dos uno que es la
materia que conocemos lo que hacen estos
cuerpos que hacemos estas estrellas lo
que hace el planeta todo lo que tocamos
vemos respiramos es una materia
ordinaria les llamamos materia bariónica
para darle un tema un tinte muy muy
científico pero básicamente es todo a
medir y que uno conoce esa materia a
través de las mediciones astrofísicas
pueden medir cuando de esta materia hay
en el universo y debemos medir porque
podemos medir la gravedad de la materia
del universo por ver cuánta materia en
total hay en el universo lo que vemos es
que hay una gran disparidad la materia
que conocemos esta materia que está en
la tabla periódica de los elementos que
una estudia en química esa materia
constituye
[Música]
un 12% 13% de toda la materia que hay en
el universo toda la otra parte de la
gran mayoría de la materia es materia
oscura la materia que sabemos están
porque vemos sus efectos gravitatorios
pero no sabemos qué es lo que es y ahora
mismo hay una gran carrera científica en
todo el mundo en el cual hay cientos
experimentos y muy muy sofisticados y
muy sensibles que están tratando de
descifrar qué es esta materia oscura de
qué se trata qué tipo de partícula
subatómica es la que la compone si es
que es así y en canadá también tenemos
muchos experimentos sobre todo en allí
en
en las minas de québec y ontario hay
experimentos que están succión
subterráneos para escapar digamos a los
efectos de la de la atmósfera de la
reactividad y de las cosas que llegan
del cielo también julio ahora para
aclararle un poco la situación de
nuestro público usted se encuentra
obviamente en canadá está si no me
equivoco en la provincia de columbia
británica allí en el oeste del país pero
es de origen argentino cuéntanos un poco
su historia por favor como se inicia por
un lado en la actividad de la física y
cómo es que llega a canadá
si yo nací en una ciudad que se llama
santiago del estero en el norte de
argentina una ciudad bastante pequeña la
provincia la provincia una de las
provincias más pobres de argentina hice
mi primaria y secundaria en santiago del
estero y por fui a estudiar en la
segunda ciudad de argentina que se llama
córdoba en sociedad en una universidad
nacional que bastante conocida en
argentina donde yo estudié hice mi
licenciatura y también mi doctorado
cuando estaba terminando mi doctorado
consigue una beca
afortunadamente prime a harvard en eeuu
en cambridge massachusetts
estuve un par de años pero límites y
síntesis fue presentada en argentinas
inicios el doctor en astronomía por la
universidad de córdoba y luego yo ya
conocía bastante personas donde estaba
trabajando y reflexión trabajo pero ni
en inglaterra donde estudié tres años en
que enbridge y entraran y después en
persona en tus son en la universidad el
son nuestro otros tres años y después de
eso ya en 1992
me ofrecieron un puesto de profesor en
la nuestra victoria el cual acepté y
donde residuo de este entonces así que
ese es el camino académico que he
llevado para terminar en canadá y
mantiene vínculos con la argentina y
específicamente con sus pares con sus
colegas de argentina si sigue teniendo
bastantes estudiantes y postdoctorados
venían a trabajar conmigo que ahora han
vuelto argentina la mayoría y por
ejemplo hay varios profesores en córdoba
que han trabajado conmigo hay profesores
universidad california en riverside hay
pues doctorados en oslo en inglaterra y
en varios lugares que han sido
supervisados por mí con otros profesores
en córdoba en particular que es el lugar
que más conozco y con el que tengo más
relaciones científicas pero es así que
está siempre muy vinculado al al
panorama científico en argentina y
siempre tratando de colaborar y de
ayudar si uno puede en todo lo posible
para terminar más allá del prestigio y
el reconocimiento que obviamente
involucran un premio y sobre todo el
premio nobel una más prestigiosos en el
campo científico que significaría para
usted lo personal obtener ese premio
personas con gran orgullo supongo
yo crecí con el 100 un país en
desarrollo en el cono sur de américa
latina el llegar a estar en jaén en boca
de personas que han tenido el nobel y lo
van a tener ya estar en ese grupo tan
selecto para mí son logros suficientes
una culminación de muchos años de podría
trabajo porque lo que hacemos nosotros
es un más un hobby por el cual nos pagan
pero muchos años de identificación de
esfuerzos dedicados a tratar de de
generar conocimiento de aprender cosas
que no sabíamos creo que en los últimos
20 años la humanidad
ha desarrollado una cantidad enorme de
conocimiento acerca de la estructura del
universo de la expansión del universo de
la historia del medio la primera vez que
me han podido mapear si no hubiera sido
así y cómo ha ido el universo desde casi
cerca al 'big band' hasta llegar a ser
lo que es ahora lo que observamos ahora
julio navarro muchas gracias por esta
entrevista con el rollo que no era
internacional no vamos a crecer ustedes